[Music]
we move on okay good good good good
watch this right oh there's a lot of
karate all right norm auntie Corday and
her Dancing with the Stars partner Val
Chmerkovskiy are ready to kick some butt
on Monday they're doing a Paso Doble for
Disney Week paying tribute to Mulan no
you the man sort of I mean her
personality's great her Energy's amazing
she's a great performer and I think we
have a great chemistry on the dance
floor as well and so you know that's
always the magic we're gonna do the dang
thing the duo have consistently earned
high scores from the judges similar to
Val's brother max whose partner Heather
Morris is slaying this season despite
the fact he's currently sidelined with
an injury what if it comes down to unit
fuzz is that gonna be gonna be it's
gonna be cold-blooded we love each other
but we were very competitive both of us
are very competitive and proud super
proud
so as proud as I am of him I'm also
proud of Nnamani and the journey that
we've been doing it at that point it's
not it's not even remotely about my
brother
this is all about us it's all about
getting her that miyamoto
[Music]
you